We had a beautiful sunny Sunday here in the
Northeast of the United States that includes
Boston and includes New York and includes
Washington DC and Donald Trump spent that
sunny Sunday exploding on Twitter and continuing
this morning.
There are some interesting vocabulary analyses
being done of Donald Trump's speech and tweets
that show significant and continued deterioration.
I'm not going to deal with that today.
We're going to deal with that tomorrow.
The topic today is the predicted predictable
erratic escalation of Donald Trump.
Since being acquitted of impeachment, we knew
it would happen and it's happening.
We don't even have the time to go through
Donald Trump's tweets individually here because
there are so many and they are so unhinged.
But let's look at just some of them and I
will summarize others.
Now understand that Donald Trump spent the
better part of the last two days tweeting.
The president has tweeted almost uninterruptedly
for the last two days.
Aside from the content of the tweets, this
is not normal.
The targets included the fake news media polling,
craze, Democrats, new York's leaders, the
TV show face the nation, Adam Schiff, Mitt
Romney, Joe mansion, Jerry Nadler, a polling
professional named Larry Sabato and many,
many more Trump tweeting about how he's winning,
winning in New Hampshire.
But the fake news media won't tell you that
tweeting about crazy Nancy Pelosi's impeachment
hoax, which has lifted Republican congressional
polls and my polls, he says way up, which
was expected, but it has had a great effect
on Republican Senate races including in a
bunch of different States.
Thanks.
He says tweeting about the crazed Dems saying
they will do anything.
Honesty and truth don't matter to them.
They are badly wounded.
Iowa vote count was a disaster for them.
Then re tweeting all sorts of what I call
Ajit trash type videos, dozens and dozens
over a period of many hours.
Then going in on Republican Senator Mitt Romney,
the only Republican to vote guilty and Trump's
impeachment on either article.
Remember Romney voted guilty just on article
one not guilty on article two Trump saying
Romney hurts some very good Republican senators
and he was wrong about the impeachment hoax.
No clue.
Remember that Mitt Romney is reportedly now
on Donald Trump's enemies to get revenge on
list.
Tow told you about that last week attacking
democratic Senator Joe mansion as quote.
They are really mad at Senator Joe munchkin
in West Virginia.
It's actually kind of funny.
He couldn't understand the transcripts.
Remember those were never released.
Romney could but didn't want to, and then
really ramping up the caps lock tweets.
Remember as we've said before, when Trump
is show up to defend Trump in my email in
livestreams tweeting to me on my Facebook
page, they engage caps, lock and turn off
spellcheck and Donald Trump doing the some
of the same here.
Starting FBI director Christopher Ray just
admitted that the Pfizer warrants and surveillance
of my campaign were illegal, misspelled surveillance,
so was the fake dossier caps lock.
Therefore, the whole scam investigation, the
Mueller report and everything else for three
years was a fixed hoax who pays the price
and then going into an almost completely capitalized
tweet to follow up.
This is the biggest political crime in American
history.
Capitalizing history by far cap sock.
Simply put the party in power illegally spied
on my campaign both before and after the election
in order to change or nullify the results
of the election.
It continued on with the impeachment hoax.
Terrible, and it continues.
Then a couple of short tweets.
Drain the swamp all in caps, make America
great again, keep America great again in all
caps and then as of this recording, Trump
with a four tweet combo today about the New
Hampshire rally that he has tonight, going
after AOC, going after Chuck Schumer, going
after the fake news media and much more.
Guys, this isn't normal.
No other president behave this way.
There are two sides to this.
You can look at the content of Donald Trump's
tweets, which is absolutely unhinged, erratic
and ridiculous, but then you can say, forget
about the content.
He's tweeting sometimes hundreds of times
in a day, tweets and retweets that alone you,
he could be tweeting about his deep knowledge
of philosophy and it would still be weird
for a president to be tweeting this much.
Other presidents did stuff most days even
they did things that we didn't like.
They were doing things.
Foreign leaders work on things.
While Trump's attention span seemingly prevents
him from having an in depth meeting without
his attention drifting to a TV showing Fox
news in the back of the room.
His briefings are down to a single page, two
bullet points, and a picture based on reporting
from inside the white house, and he is just
tweeting all day.
The one, I don't even know to call it a silver
lining, but the one response that sometimes
people have to the endless erratic, unhinged
tweeting is that if he's spending this much
time tweeting, he's spending less time doing
things that damage the country.
That's the one pseudo silver lining that sometimes
people find.
We're going to have more about this on the
show's Instagram page.
Make sure you were following it at David Pakman
show and make sure you follow me on Instagram
at David dot [inaudible]
Hackman.
I posted a pricky pretty wacky hate mail.
I got this morning on my Instagram page at
David dot captains